thank you
[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of be careful boys uh featuring
Jesus yeah baby oh my god
oh you're on a sybian sorry man sorry
this is a family show man that girl was
[ __ ] oh my goodness sorry that's you
know anyways what was that thank you
thank you for having me hell yeah
speaking of families aren't you starting
yes dude I'm a brand new daddy dude
[Applause]
I gotta change all that dude I'm a
[ __ ] brand new day you got it you got
a boy or girl you got a boy man hell
yeah baby
salute that zone [ __ ] right there did
you have a uh say in the name did you
say I have a say in the name or was just
like my my lady do all that what do you
mean who named it yeah who named it oh
dude dude that was a big one for me
because like my [ __ ] Mexican family
was like oh you got to be Jesus you're a
junior because I'm a junior
so was it a junior junior you got to
pass it down so yeah so I'm a junior so
I was gonna give him Jesus too so he's
like Jesus the second the third oh yeah
yeah yeah
whoops the way math Works no but but
yeah so I was gonna you know I didn't
even think of it and I was just told my
girl like okay it's gonna be you know he
says he's like yeah no yeah I was like
excuse me [ __ ]
excuse me like what do you mean she's
like yeah like no let's get him like
anyway
right how about I get Bailey you know
dude these [ __ ] new girls dude I
swear to God I was like uh I guess but
she kind of like made sense she maybe
she mind [ __ ] me what's her sense we
should name it donut because it's like
why he gave him a name give him like a
brand new store give him his own
identity like let's just name him
something else because in the end of the
day I was like yeah I didn't really like
him it was hard for people to pronounce
I wish I had like a different name but
Jesus is hard to pronounce for white
people Jesus Jesus Jesus
and they always say a stupid joke about
it Jose Jesse like they don't know how
to say just Jesus Jesus suggested they
call you Jose all the time dude for real
I'm gonna get me started dude that's
crazy and so I told her like all right
what do you want to name him so we
picked the name together and I we named
him Max right and I was like I like it
it's a strong name short short for
anything like not just Maps just [ __ ]
Max I always liked it I always felt
strong it just feels like a cool name
like Max you know did they use my show
for Maximilian Jesus Sepulveda like so
max issue supported right so I go back
and that's it and I go back home middle
name you got to keep your name for them
but then I go back home and I tell my
Latino family I'm just like oh no my
dad's like oh sorry
baby Jesus is like no he's actually me
Max Max King now I'm known as
dude now I'm known as like the most
bitchiest person in the he's like you're
gonna let her choose the he doesn't say
you mean but his name come on okay you
gotta have to go back over there and
tell her
but you did name him Jesus though yeah
his middle name the traditional yeah
it's not enough so he was I would have
been like yeah no dude and then he finds
out later and disowns me dude [ __ ] so
now everything is like I'm not a man so
what are you say excuse me the people
like he's like my uncles hey [ __ ]
like oh you want to eat a taco and [ __ ]
like that you gotta ask his wife because
he doesn't have balls
[ __ ] you're wearing the [ __ ] grocery
stores like look is that your son yeah
but I know Mario's a woman now oh he's
transitioning like
I can't talk [ __ ] to my dad dude he wins
he wins every time dude he just has more
years of experience
with the Latina family if you [ __ ] up
once that's your nickname for the rest
of your life oh for sure dude anything
you [ __ ] up on they can't take you
seriously like you can be a [ __ ]
manager bro you can graduate from
Harvard and they'll still remember like
meet you at the yeah he got a graduation
from Harbor but he peed his pants
[Laughter]
no matter what you do in your life you
still ain't [ __ ] to them like I [ __ ]
dude I told him all the time I was like
oh yeah you know I'm an HBO now this and
that everybody's just like oh my gosh on
HBO your son wow he's just like yeah but
he can't read
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] awesome or something a
compliment yeah dude I'm just gonna
change all that with my son I'm gonna
change it do you have any new Life views
since having a son yeah dude I'm not
[ __ ] like I used to I'm like this is
dangerous dude it's got some time out
dude so I can change your life I told
girls like back up I'm gonna ruin your
[ __ ] life let me tell you something
right now I'm gonna [ __ ] for life for
nine months at least nah but
definitely like I want to be more
bonding I was like I want to be more
bonding how do you do that with a baby
just crying like hi because I do this
thing I did this thing dude called skin
to skin have you ever done that did you
do skin yeah what's that that's what you
took off your shirt you're you're you
know shirtless at the hospital sure yeah
and right away you just put him skinny
skin so he can bond with the debt so I
was like looking at him like man we're
attaching right now we're bonding and I
remember telling my dad like oh did you
ever do it
I was drunk
bonding with my friends in the beer
because I was going on with the corona
so you can't do so those are things that
I'm just like ah well I guess I want to
change that I want to have more like
understanding when my son asking
questions and [ __ ] instead of just
telling them what to do I think so yeah
I
like all the guys in our dad's
generation think all of us are gay yeah
no matter what culture they're like
all the time it's just because I didn't
like like he I got menulo and he's like
oh hey you want I want my stomach is
like gay boy over here
because it tickles my butthole and you
think you like it because I'm like no
it's good you think you like it it gives
me gastritis
he's like indigestion all right whatever
the [ __ ] on my stomach because you're
doing butt things come on stop reading
like that
I'm like what so yeah so everything is
gay right I remember the gayest thing to
my dad that I had to convince him for
years that I wasn't gay was when I
wanted a sleepover at my friend's house
you know your friend Tyler she's like
hey dude we're all gonna [ __ ] sleep
over come dude that sounds like fun what
do you guys do play video games and eat
snacks
what
he couldn't do this he almost crashed
the car did I get you now what
wait okay what do you want to do I want
to go to Tyler's house to sleep over
sleep over with a boy
it's not just me where it's like five
boys five boys
is there a girls is there gonna be girls
like no no girls why I don't understand
why you want to sleep with boys why
would you want to sleep with boys and I
was like
now I'm questioning my [ __ ] like uh yeah
why do I want to sleep with boys I don't
know something wrong with you girl I
gotta get my eye on your card
numbers because I think this guy I think
this guy you're gonna do things with the
cucumbers and the bananas hide the
bananas he's getting he's getting
curious so that was a lot of [ __ ] like I
remember you're not gonna do that to
your kid nah don't let him [ __ ] go
over there
turn over to his friend's house and
probably get molested by the guy's dad
or something
they're like I don't know a lot of our
parents didn't understand sleepovers
though yeah well think about it it's
[ __ ] weird they didn't know what that
was that's purely America why are you
gonna sleep at someone else's house
that's American for sure it was an
immigrant which he didn't even trust the
government right to trust in other guys
[ __ ] house and the guy's dad he did
that to him was like they're kind of
right though they're right well if you
think about it they're right yeah but
you know you know why kids you know they
don't [ __ ] yeah everything is
innocent and lovely and [ __ ]
my parents are freaked out little people
coming over because they said if that
kids slipped in our house his parents
are because yes yes I got lawyers yeah
yeah like that yes that's true to my dad
I hated having people over to the house
you just [ __ ] hated how's my parents
like not just sleeping over but just
coming over to kicking everyone one time
I invited a friend over my dad came out
of the road
and I was like hey what's up what the
[ __ ] is that
I was like oh dude that's my best friend
or best friend get on the hell out of
here he doesn't have a house yelling for
you can hear you don't have a house
well yeah he has a house but he's just
coming over to my house and still like
no no no no no one nobody and I got that
house nobody in the house I think he's
gonna want to eat something
like why are you bringing these Strays
oh yeah dude one time I made a mistake
of getting uh my friend like a Capri Sun
my dad sees it he's like
I paid
foreign
ever dude
so we were the first one in the
neighborhood to get internet dude like I
remember the first ones to get a
computer and internet in the block right
it was just like and that's when the
console was out so I was making like
burn CDs I was burning CDs but I've
already entered used to come in a CD in
a disc like AOL yeah remember that [ __ ]
like the trial the trial one yeah so one
day my dad never [ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
about the internet all of a sudden this
day he just like all right let me see
what are you doing I got that computer
let me see how the internet work and I'm
burning the CD for my friend for some
reason it's not working there's
something wrong with the Internet it's
not connecting I was like what the [ __ ]
and my dad's like check out when I want
to use it nothing works in this [ __ ]
house I'm like hold on hold on give me a
minute I'm trying to I'm trying to I
feel like I'm cracking a code or
something what the [ __ ] am I doing I
connected the wire what the hell and I
get a knock at the door and my friend
shows up and I'm giving him the burden
CD so I think he I give him the burn
City oh here you go take it out the disc
can I give it to him and then come back
and I'll work on the computer my dad in
his mind he's like ah okay I know what
you're doing okay yeah I told my mom hey
come here you know what he's doing and I
was like what he's like he's burning the
internet in the CD he's learning the
internet in the city and giving it to
his [ __ ] friends
what the whole internet
and that's the internet and giving it to
my friends like I pay every month for
internet for him to just give it away
yeah
that's that's impossible give me the
goddamn CD camera I'll show you and I
[ __ ] had to run and tell my friend
like no dude can I get the disc I can
show my dad and all my friends confused
I come back and I and from yelling at me
over and over I start believing I'm like
did I did I did I drag the internet
inside
he starts [ __ ] with you you start
believing their [ __ ] anger so you're
like what the [ __ ] did I do dude turns
out that I just disconnected it from my
the thing so the thing got disconnected
I just connected I'm like oh that's what
happens
it was a CD that's why I got you thank
God I brought it back a little don't be
giving it to your [ __ ] friends I'm
like you're [ __ ] the internet away he
thought I gave it away to the whole
neighborhood that's so funny he's
working every [ __ ] month to pay for
the bill for me to just give it away I
was like dude that is impossible that
[ __ ] was expensive back then too yeah it
was dude didn't understand what made him
like want to get internet in your house
that's a hard sell because I we all said
because school oh you scored it's better
and it is because it has encyclopedia
and grades even your siblings fought to
like beg to get it yeah dude we were
[ __ ] how many brothers and sisters do
you have uh I have an older sister uh
younger brother and that was it for now
until like later my dad's you know you
know Latinos they keep [ __ ] they have
a baby all of a sudden we're like we're
all grown and you got another baby like
damn what the [ __ ] yeah we have a baby
brother I was in high school with a baby
brother I'm like what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah dude they kept going so yeah so at
that time we were like fighting for the
internet and we convinced him like oh
man if you gave me the internet I'll get
better grades and ah that [ __ ] didn't
work for me yeah I just kept [ __ ]
like my [ __ ] kept going downhill dude
yeah but that was a craziest idea for
him to think about I'm giving the
internet away dude he was a wild person
bro do you see a different side of your
dad now that he's a grandpa yes
are you the first out of the three
siblings oh my sister has like three
kids you know she she'd be [ __ ] oh
but my sister has like three kids and
then but this is like the first like
Sepulveda he has my last name yeah so I
can see it that way kids like aren't
even his really well yeah yeah whoa whoa
whoa they're they're light skin for sure
we want to say that way but but yeah
he's like the first supporter but I
understand my dad now like I understand
everything he did everything I
complained about yeah has gone away yeah
like any Grudge that they hold against
my parents are it's gone because now I
accept that they were doing everything
they could yeah for us giving away
internet because this stupid
[ __ ] no but I get it because you
know what do we do because well at least
what I did I would throw I had like
years of throwing [ __ ] at their faces
like oh you never [ __ ] you know gave
me attention or you never did this for
me I wanted this he never did that and I
would always talk [ __ ] and I would
always just always tell like everything
I went through that was tough I was like
this is hard because of you you never
helped down this night he's like what
about me he said what about me I came to
this country I didn't know the language
and nobody's helping me out but yeah you
don't see that you just see everything I
did wrong but what did I do right yeah I
brought you here you're here you're your
citizen is like hey but you want to
attend me all the wrongs when are you
gonna start talking about the rights and
I'm like damn dog what the [ __ ] am I you
know now I felt like well I guess you're
right I guess I am a [ __ ] spoiled
brat internet
yeah that is pretty crazy dumb [ __ ] that
I just like look at the bad but then
that's just you being a kid though yeah
and as a parent now I'm just kind of
like I'm like damn dude I don't know how
they did it with three yeah and he
didn't speak the language and he was an
immigrant you know how the [ __ ] did they
make that happen it's crazy it's always
nice to think about that [ __ ] man I'm
quick to [ __ ] talk [ __ ] and be like
oh yeah I had it hard but it's so funny
to like
I can never talk about any anything bad
because in
he'll always like flip it right I would
always be like oh because I was on
FaceTiming them and I kind of want him
to be like have like a father and dad
moment I was like look it I had my son I
was like man it's hard and you know it's
a it's gonna be hard I'm a little scared
but you know I'm just gonna keep I'm
gonna make it happen regardless of my
son you know and my dad's like is that
heart chinga heart heart that's not hard
come on hard as being an immigrant what
no job because I only had five dollars
and I'm like Dan can you give me a
little bit of problems something that
I'm going through right now and we would
focus about me right now my dad's just
like [ __ ] heart you know I had three
kids I don't even know if you were
Minecon
amazing not three of them
talking about hard he's all you can
never talk about any complaining to your
immigrant parents right that's so funny
it's so hard right it's [ __ ] I mean
do you guys did you guys grow up with
immigrant parents or yeah oh [ __ ] but do
you feel like that might like rub off
onto your child like you know 15 20
years from now you know what I'm saying
I mean I'd probably be the old guy going
like can we imagine like uh if you think
you had it hard
I think the hard part of a second
generation parent is like you know when
you have an immigrant parent you have
like these really hard values that are
dope but then the hard values are also
like half as toxic and half of it is
actually really productive yeah so
trying to like in the moment go like oh
[ __ ] here are the tools that I was given
which ones [ __ ] me up and which ones
were good and then trying to make sure
they go through yeah dude but also
what's cool about the second generation
or whatever like it's like we can help
with homework and stuff and field trips
and like little things like that might
not seem like a lot but it was growing
up I I didn't think I was worthy for a
field trip I honestly did not think like
I thought that was just for the white
people I'm like oh that's for them I
never thought it was for me because my
my parents lived like that my parents
were like oh no they're they're the
images
you know what I mean like I didn't know
that I felt like I didn't belong in this
country because they didn't belong yeah
and everything was about no no like in
school it's like hey don't
like even if you got like an honorable
he would get a nerd my dad would get my
sister's like oh I got an honor roll we
gotta go do an assembly they want the
parents
don't do these things
don't be so smart
attention
they want to give me an award okay tell
them to give it to the male no way they
want okay one problem
then my dad would show up all [ __ ]
Batman stuff I was watching my sister
get to work
I'm I'm her friend I don't knock her dad
just in case dude just in case
very secretive dude he's [ __ ] he
didn't like any attention bro his foot
was [ __ ] hidden bro this [ __ ] was
[ __ ] crazy even when it's good yeah
how's your dad dude before it works he
was a welder it was like okay yeah it
was like that's tough too oh yeah to him
like if he got a desk job
[Laughter]
my [ __ ]
yo all of my classmates in college that
were Mexican they said that like when
they try to pursue higher education all
of their family members call them gay oh
yeah and you're just like yo I'm just
trying to they're like you still in
school why don't you work they're like
I'm finishing up my freaking Masters bro
and they're like oh you think it's so
smart shut up dude they don't get that
[ __ ] and that yeah when it comes to like
education he was all like go for
education but then he also like said
it's like you're not gonna get good
grades just get a job already I was like
bro I'm like 13. you're still home I
in the Summers I would wear construction
dude I'll be like that Mexican kid that
shows up in the truck yeah but his daddy
and I have to like translate with my dad
sometimes I was like you know my it was
so funny I like when I worked with my
dad he was afraid to talk [ __ ] to the
guy but he'll talk [ __ ] to me
right because he's afraid to tell the
owner anything but he'll talk [ __ ] to me
he doesn't want to lose his job you
don't want to lose his job and [ __ ] but
then he's like okay you'll talk [ __ ] the
whole right over there [ __ ] then John I
swear to God if he told me to re do the
side of the house I'm gonna that's it
I'm gonna [ __ ] tell him I'm gonna
punch him in the face and I'm just
hearing him he's just talking [ __ ] the
whole time five in the morning and I'm
like all right Dad relax he shows up Mr
Johnson come on good morning
okay Mr Johnson's just like yeah uh Leo
we're gonna talk to you for a second so
the side of the house can we just redo
that I don't think we want that extra
okay oh you want me to redo that side uh
even I did three hours but okay okay you
want me to I get rid of the house okay
and then he leaves he's like yeah
about it come up do something you
think
don't take out on me don't take it out
on me right now
you worked on three hours don't try to
take it out does not go grab something
like a [ __ ] idiot
man do something stand straight
you guys are [ __ ] stupid face
thinking about dicks all day good don't
do something
[Laughter]
unloading things just because he didn't
get his way you know but that was him
dude oh yeah working with him was a
[ __ ] trip you guys ever work with
your families yeah thank God no Vlogs
right it was at a dry cleaners every
[ __ ] oh dude they can they feel like
they can talk to you a certain way never
ends haven't you noticed that like
other people at work they talk to him
friendly but with family like my dad
would [ __ ] will work with somebody
else and just be like hey can I please
call them I was like please what the
[ __ ] who's this guy yeah please get the
screws yeah yeah thank you so much and
with me hey stupid
I can't do this I've done that [ __ ] I
told my mom talk to me like Sean and
[ __ ] at the dry cleaners my mom be the
one in the front talking to customers or
something I remember one time I got so
frustrated I was like why don't you talk
to me like you talked to customers
hell of a thing to say that [ __ ] is so
different right she's like oh hi we're
close
she was like
in the back
[Music]
[Music]